we will now continue and derive some
additional properties of probability
laws which are again consequences of the
axioms that we have introduced the first
property is the following if we have two
sets and one set is smaller than the
other so we have a picture as follows we
have our sample space and we have a
certain set a and then we have a certain
set B which is even bigger so the set B
is the bigger blue set so if B is a set
which is larger than a then naturally
the probability that the outcome falls
inside B should be at least as big as
the probability that the outcome falls
inside a how do we prove this formally
the set B can be expressed as a union of
two pieces one piece is the set a itself
the second piece is whatever elements of
B there are that do not belong in a what
are these elements they are elements
that belong to B and they do not belong
to a which means that they belong to the
complement of a so we have expressed the
set B as the union of two pieces now
this piece is a this piece here is
outside a so these two pieces are
disjoint and so we can apply the
additivity axiom and write that the
probability of B is equal to the
probability of a plus the probability of
the other set and since probabilities
are non-negative this expression here is
at least as large as the probability of
a and this concludes the proof of the
property that we wanted to show indeed
the probability of a is less than or
equal to the probability of B
the next property we will show is the
following it allows us to write the
probability of the union of two sets for
the case now where the two sets are not
necessarily disjoint so the picture is
as follows
we have our two sets a and B these sets
are not necessarily disjoint and we want
to say something about the probability
of the union of a and B okay now the
union of a and B consists of three
pieces one piece is this one here and
that piece consists of those elements of
a that do not belong to B so they belong
to B complement this set has a certain
probability let's call it little a and
indicate it on this diagram so a is the
probability of this piece another piece
is this one here which is the
intersection of a and B it has a certain
probability that we denote by little B
this is the probability of a
intersection B and finally there's
another piece which is out here and that
piece has a certain probability C it's
the probability of that set and what is
that set that set is the following it's
that part of B that consists of elements
that do not belong in a so it's B
intersection with the complement of a
now let's express the two sides of this
equality here in terms of little a
little B and little C and see whether we
get the same thing so the probability of
a union B a union B consists of these
three pieces that have probabilities a
little a little B and little C
effectively and by the additivity axiom
the probability of the union of a and B
is the sum of the probabilities of these
three pieces let's look now at the right
hand side of that equation and see
whether we get the same thing the
probability of a plus the probability of
B minus the probability of a
intersection B is equal to the following
a consists of two pieces that have
probabilities little a and little B the
set B consists of two pieces that have
probabilities little B and little C and
then we subtract the probability of the
intersection which is B and we notice
that we can cancel here one be with
another B and what we are left with is a
plus B plus C so this checks and indeed
we have this equality here we have
verified that it is true one particular
consequence of the Equality that we
derived is the following since this term
here is always non-negative this means
that the probability of a union B is
always less than or equal to the
probability of a plus the probability of
B this inequality here is quite useful
whenever we want to argue that the
certain probability is smaller than
something and it has a name it's called
the Union bound we finally consider one
last consequence of our axioms and
namely we're going to derive an
expression a way of calculating the
probability of a union of three sets
not necessarily disjoint so we have our
sample space and within the sample space
there are three sets set a
set B and set C we're going to use a set
theoretic relation we're going to
express the union of these three sets as
the union of three disjoint pieces
what are these disjoint pieces one piece
is the set a itself the second piece is
going to be that part of B which is
outside a so this is the intersection of
B with the complement of a the third
piece is going to be whatever is left in
order to form the union of the three
sets what is left is that part of C that
does not belong to a and that does not
belong in to B so that part is C
intersection with a complement and B
complement now this set here of course
is the same as that said because
intersection of two set is the same no
matter in which order we take the two
sets and similarly the set that we have
here is the same one that appears in
that expression now we notice that these
three pieces the red the blue and the
green are disjoint from each other
so by the additivity axiom the
probability of this Union here is going
to be the sum of the probabilities of
the three pieces and that's exactly the
expression that we have up here